dimitri de kochko
journaliste présidents d'associations
stop russophobie bonsoir monsieur merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on l'a entendu échange tendu entre les
deux diplomates quel regard vous portez
sur ses déclarations
alors là vous pu me l'expliquer en fait
il a dit que c'est vrai que les
américains et notamment blinken a
commencé tout un lot d'accusations
contre la russie sur le fait qu'elle ne
respecterait pas les accords de minsk
sur le dôme basse or la russie n'est pas
partie prenante
donc il a refait distribué à tous les
participants donc tous les ministres des
affaires étrangères de cette conférence
il a fait distribuer le texte de des
accords de minx qui ont été donc votée
par le conseil de sécurité de l'onu je
vous rappelle et qui permettent de voir
que en fait ce sont les républiques
renom reconnu de lougansk de donetsk et
kiev qui sont partie prenante des
négociations et que la russie est au
même titre que la france et l'allemagne
un des pays observateurs est un des pays
chargés de faire appliquer ces accords
de minsk qui ne sont pas appliquées par
kiev
donc il a dit il n'empêche que nous
pouvons quand même discuté nous
considérons que c'est quand même utile
de discuter avec lync n lors de cette
conférence puisque les américains sont
en fait la puissance décisionnaires en
ukraine c'est eux qui prennent les
décisions en fait d'une part et
deuxièmement parce que monsieur bling
qu'elle m'a bien confirmé qu'il ne
cherchait pas à elle lire le format de
normandie des accords de minsk c'est à
dire celui justement de la france de
l'allemagne de la russie et de l'ukraine
avec ces deux régions qui n'ont pas
accepté le coup d'état de 2014 alors en
tout cas le ton est loin d'être cordiale
entre les deux pays si la russie décidé
de continuer sur la voie de la
confrontation elle subira de graves
conséquences a prévenu blinken
washington qui dénonce notamment une
agression contre l'ukraine moscou risque
qui est qui a une tous les sites de
pression contre qui que ce soit c'est
d'ailleurs bondi l'idée de nouvelles
sanctions mais mais sur quelle base
juridique on se demande toujours ces
histoires de sanctions qui l'est moins
c'est exactement que répondait en fait
la brosse dans la citation que vous avez
que vous avez montré tout à l'heure il
parlait pas du tout de la ce moment-là
de conflit militaire
mil concentration de troupes dont il
évidemment qui n'existe pas vraiment
c'est ce qu'il a dit en fait c'est que
les occidentaux malheureusement n'avait
plus que le mot de sanctions à la bouche
et qu'ils étaient en train d'en monter
sans arrêt et qu'on en arrive et une
négation totale de relations
diplomatiques et de capacités de
négociation donc il dit finalement entre
toutes les façons ça se retourne contre
ceux qui instaure en permanence ces
sanctions et dire des conséquences
internes ans sur les échanges non
seulement diplomatique politique mais
aussi économique
non il n'y a aucun fondement juridique
même je dirais il vient que des
lieux nation juridique aussi bien du
droit international disons qu'ils
seraient garanties par l'onu que ce qui
a pu exister au niveau des accords
commerciaux et de libre échange au
niveau mondial donc bien évidemment qui
n'a pas de fondement juridique à ces
sanctions y'a que des fondements
politiques du rapport de force alors
jobs et de l'année venir poutine devrait
du coup s'entretenir prochainement dont
dans la continuité de cette réunion
entre les deux hommes aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on peut attendre de ce rendez-vous
plutôt une accalmie un réchauffement de
la relation
c'est difficile à dire il vous savez
qu'on paye des néo poutine se sont
rencontrés à genève
et c'était un moment de grande tension
là aussi notamment en ukraine est tout
le problème est là c'est que en ce
moment il y a à l'intérieur de l'ukraine
une crise politique assez forte et quand
même donc on peut craindre des des
fuites en avant notamment du président
de l'unss qui qui a été visiblement
lâchée par un certain nombre de ses
soutiens
et on peut dire que il est assez
inquiétant effectivement que
cette surenchère de l'otan et de
l'ukraine qui parle de coup d'état
évidemment organisé par la russie
puisque tout ce qui se passe à l'écran
une toujours organisé par la réussite
que le fait que c'est un ski part du
fait que l'ukraine étant est en guerre
contre la russie alors que lui même
s'est retrouvé quelquefois à des
cérémonies à quelques pas très très loin
de la frontière russe et en toute
sécurité
c'est assez c'est assez c'est assez
inquiétant parce qu'on est à la merci de
n'importe quelle provocation qui peut
mettre le feu aux poudres effectivement
ça a été le cas déjà donc au printemps
au moment au bail des années poutine se
rencontrer et il a fallu que poutine
fasse une déclaration en rappelant les
possibilités de la russie en matière de
missiles
hypersonique et qu'il a fallu que
quelques démonstrations militaires de
transport de troupes très rapide ont pu
être faites à l'intérieur de la russie
pour que
pour que joe biden des fils de
rencontrer poutine et de discuter sur un
autre ton que simplement la guerre de
l'information que nous subissons tout le
temps de dans la plupart malheureusement
de nos médias en france aussi ce qui est
très dommage parce que la france n'a pas
forcément ses intérêts là et la france
est logiquement à des pays garants de
l'application
des accords de minsk or
une assistante à
merci dimitri de kochko d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france